well now get that total moon om or if
I'm about the shuttle by mati oh I'm
sorry this this is my English Channel
sorry sorry sorry yeah
the end of this week we starting my
Spanish Channel up and I started up and
so for those of you who are interested
well I'm gonna be putting the link in
the description I want to remind
everyone that I do have a book out we
uploaded I think a couple weeks 10 days
ago now the Rope hypothesis tells you a
little bit about the new vision of the
universe how it works and you can
download that book at rope hypothesis
calm it's free Illustrated ok if you can
translate it to some language your
native language well please contact us
at toca cock-eyed hotmail.com ok we'll
be glad to send you a file that you can
modify and if you translate it since
back world will upload it for you ok and
your get put your name in lights and we
thank you in advance okay well what am I
gonna talk about today I'm gonna talk
about time what is time
the mathematician say it's the fourth
dimension okay so we have time the
fourth dimension where did they get this
okay someone had a bad dream a nightmare
in something well let's go a little bit
through the sea we can get to to the
bottom of it to some degree okay see if
we can figure out how they came up with
this notion that time is is a dimension
it wasn't always by the way okay times
minute dimension only for the last maybe
hundred years more or less
before that time was not a dimension and
that's what I want to look at that
little history okay today okay so we
start with as usual with the Greeks
because that's where we inherited a lot
of our notions of geometry and I'd say
all of them really because that's that's
the foundation of mathematics started in
Greece okay so we have to give credit to
the Greeks for this know no doubt about
it and we had on one hand like I said
the other day mr. Aristotle gay and he
was interested in what we could call
physics science he was interested in
explaining how this universe works okay
and so he applied points and lines to
things such as location distance
distance traveled motion time okay he
also used number okay and that
contrasted with a fellow who came one or
two generations later we don't know when
you click was born okay or when he died
but Euclid wrote a book called elements
in and he synthesized the notions the
Greeks had of geometry specifically as a
foundation for mathematics okay so he
used point line plane etc but he used
them for geometry
whereas Aristotle used them for to try
to figure out them I guess you could say
the foundations of physics that's why
his book is called physics okay so
that's our starting point so we're not
gonna be interested in Euclid right now
we're gonna be interested in Aristotle
because the notion that time is a
dimension has little really to do with
geometry it has to do with try and
explain gravity you know warpage of
space time for dimension all space-time
it has to do with a lot of that and and
that the starting point is Aristotle
absolutely not
you okay so let's go with mister area
here and the first notion he tries to
stuck in stone you could say the first
fountain
stone is the notion of of what they what
motion is okay and he's gonna start by
using the word lying to simulate motion
okay so he says locomotion in a regular
path example in a circle or on a
straight line so you're gonna see that
word lying constantly related to
locomotion motion okay a motion cannot
be regular if its path is an irregular
magnitude example broken line gay spiral
or other magnitude again he uses
magnitude to talk about motion okay and
he relates magnitude to laces or any
other magnitude so they're not thinking
of line as a geometric figure they're
thinking of line as a magnitude some
number on a number line what else can
you call it okay
system in a straight line okay for the
shortest line is definitely limited and
that which is definitely limited
constitutes a measure started about
measuring now okay measuring numbers
without about a number line that's what
the line means to them they're not gonna
use the at least Aristotle he's not
gonna use the line to talk about
geometry he's going to use the line as
it is used today by relativists and
mechanics quantum mechanics okay and
they're gonna use it in Lu to
pictorially debate motion that's
essentially where where these guys are
at okay
a thing is in succession when it is
after the beginning in position or in
form and went further there is nothing
of the same kind as itself between it
and that to which it is in succession
example align a unit when he talks about
Union he's talking about numbers he's
talking about dots points that's that's
what he means when he talks about Union
okay so you can see he's gonna use the
point a line and he's gonna talk about
position or location place as he called
it and he's gonna be talking about
motion and
okay the this is where he's headed okay
and yeah the first thing he has to
define is continuous what does he mean
by this adjective he calls continuous
and here we have a major discrepancy
between physics rational physics and
what all of mathematics means by
continues okay so mathematical physics
physicists they follow Aristotle
rational people don't okay so let's make
sure that you understand that so what is
it Aristotle say for continued says no
continuous thing is divisible into
things without parts in other words
according to Aristotle something that is
continues is segments made of parts of
discrete points okay if it is divisible
it must be divisible either in two
indivisible x' or in two divisible that
are infinitely divisible in which case
it is continuous okay so these are
essentially different ways of saying the
same thing neither line or a surface nor
surface also meaning planes right nor in
fact anything continues can be
indivisible everything has to be
divisible if it wants to be continuous
okay and eyes may be infinitely divided
well you see there the two notions that
we have one from Aristotle you know the
other one from rational physics and
according to rational physics continues
means made of a single piece Aristotle
and his mathematicians all the people
that followed him they think of
continuous as something which can be
broken up into pieces and so the
question comes up whether if you have
all these dots pieces squares whatever
you want to call them all these little
pieces that form this continuous
structure how is one little piece
separated from the next one obviously
you got a bump because you got a jump a
divide that's a some kind of space that
divides these constituents you can't
avoid it okay and here I'll give you an
example is the Rubik
you okay imagine that that's a square
gay and it's made out of squares all
those black lines that divide each one
of these squares or even for the cube
okay you know there's you got to jump
over that line to get to the other
square and so no matter how you look at
it if if a if a square or a cube is made
out of parts right each part is separate
from the next one down then it cannot be
continuous according to what a rational
human would call continuous now
obviously only if it's made out of a
single piece as something continuous and
we can use that notion to talk about
something that is continuous in an ideal
frame okay my frame of discussion but
you cannot use the concept that
Aristotle has and all the mathematicians
have for what they think is continuous
which is something and something made of
pieces okay segment it here's an example
okay here is this continuous here you
have a triangle and it's made out of all
these little points would you think that
that's continuous at a smooth surface
and here compared against this okay
how's that so something that is
continuous made of a single piece and
not made of points as the mathematicians
or Aristotle would have you believed
okay so this is the issue the issue is
he starts off at the wrong foot because
he's going to be talking about motion
and he's going to be a motion with
locations and a location is a point a
dot that's what he's gonna depict it
with right that's his pictorial
representation of a location of a
position of a place as he called it he's
gonna use the unit or he's going to use
the dot the point to represent it and of
course if one point is separated from
another point well then you don't have
continuity
except according to him because he says
between a 92 point you'll find another
point or you'll find a line and the line
is made of points so it's and it's
infinitely divisible so this is this is
the notion that we have a problem with
it's conceptually wrong conceptually
irrational with what one irrational
human being understands by continuity
okay okay
and again you can dispute that if what
and I don't want you disputing it from a
mathematical point of view you need to
challenge it from a physical point of
view what do you mean by continues okay
and of course in in ordinary days
nothing is continuous everything is
discrete except under the rope model the
original thread the the lonely thread
that forms all of matter that's the only
thing we say is continuous made of a
single piece okay but you'll have to go
to the book to find out what that's
about
okay so what does area do next well he
did he define Street or identifies three
types of motion okay and here they are
this comes from his book v one thing
causes motion accidentally another
partially because something belonging to
it causes motion another of itself
directly that which directly causes
motion that which is in motion and that
which and that in which motion takes
place namely time now he introduces time
there okay and that from which and that
to which it proceeds okay and he adds he
says for every motion proceeds from
something and to something that which is
directly in motion being distinct from
that to which it is in motion towards
right and that from which it is in
motion so he's talking running away
going to something approaching something
okay he's talking about the object
itself doing the motion and he does give
some examples okay here's a
one of the examples that he gives or a
couple of the examples he says take the
three things would hot and cold okay he
calls him things hot and cold they're
concepts but he calls them things again
another note another evidence you could
say that that he doesn't do you find a
word object he doesn't say and tell you
what a thing is okay or he doesn't
identify that and he says the first is
that which is in motion the second is
that to which the motion proceeds and
the third is that from which it proceeds
okay motion is in the would not in his
form for the motion is neither cause nor
experience by the form or the place or
the quantity so we are left with a mover
a moved any goal of motion
I do not include the starting point of
motion for it is the goal rather than
the starting point of motion that gives
its name to a particular process of
change
thus perishing is changed to not being
and becoming is change to being that
more or less is his notion of existence
or coming into existence that's what
he's talking about okay so he makes he
makes sure you understand that one of
the prongs we have today if you look up
the word motion or movement and they'll
say a change in position or whatever
change in place or whatever nonsense the
ordinary dictionary has which is what
the mathematicians had and it turns out
that Aristotle specifically stated that
motion and change are two different
words they're not synonyms okay and so
he he says that here in his book okay he
says Monkman has changed from one form
to another where a change implies a pair
of opposites alteration if you go from
hot to cold you changed you it's it's a
type of motion but it's a it's not
exactly the same thing as change okay
because the motion is actually changing
form whereas change requires that you go
to your opposite you have to turn black
into wider or Audion to off that sort of
thing that's what he was referring to
okay and of course he goes from there to
time
okay jumps over because now he's got two
foundations he's got continuity under
one hand and on the other one he's got
motion he's got a notion of motion okay
and so he moves on to time he says the
science of nature is concerned with
spatial magnitudes and motion and time
talking about physics okay he's gonna
set like the foundations of physics here
and each of these at least is
necessarily infinite or finite that's
concerned him a lot whether something is
finite or infinite yes the Greeks dealt
a lot with this issue infinity right and
that's why they got into numbers they
realized they could count forever in
there conceptually so they got into this
notion of infinity and they always
related to numbers you can't you can't
introduce infinity unless you've got
mathematic in other words you've got
arithmetic you need the number line you
need that those numbers to go off into
nowhere land wherever infinity is that's
where you'll find the last number so
guard find it right
hence it is incumbent on the person who
specializes in physics to discuss the
infinite and to inquire whether there is
such a thing or not if there is what it
is not own in physics now maybe in
mathematics in physics we care not one
Yoda about infinity okay but that was
his notion and that's the notion the
mathematicians have today mathematical
physicists they call themselves belief
in the existence of the infinite comes
mainly from five considerations and the
first one I'm not gonna mention the
others from the nature of time for it is
infinite already Airy is telling us that
time is infinite why because what we're
gonna find out what time is in a second
here but he's saying it's infinite and
obviously like I said a minute ago is
something related to numbers or the
number line because the number lines or
the number of numbers is infinite
you can count until you die if you want
and beyond even when you go to heaven
you can continue counting okay that's
time belong to the class of things that
exist or to the or to that of things
that do not exist he asks this question
does time exist and this is about it
question does time exist and for that we
need to define the word exist which mr.
Airy
and no one since none has ever defined
okay now we define it in rational
physics and rational science we defined
the word exist so now we can use it
consistently okay and in order for
something to exist the first thing it's
got to be as a thing it's got to be a
something it's got to be a an object a
medium a substance it's it's got to have
shape if it doesn't have shape you can't
apply the word exist to it you cannot
say love exists intelligence exists
information it is you cannot say that
not in physics not in science you can
say that in ordinary speech and that's
where people get confused because they
want to extrapolate the notions we have
in ordinary speech directly into science
indiscriminately you can't do that in
physics you get or science in general
you have to define the term first then
you can use it to qualify whatever you
want okay and so we defined the word
exist as an object that has location
okay so it's got to be an object and
it's not sufficient it's got to also
have location
God wants to exist he's gotta be an
object first it's gotta have shape and
then he's got to have location otherwise
poor old God does not exist
sorry and if God has shape but he's only
in your brain and you see an old man
there in your eye above he still doesn't
exist he has no location your your
thoughts don't have location your brain
does but every atom in there but not God
okay okay so so yeah we have a problem
because he hasn't defined Aristotle
hasn't defined what he means by exist
and he asks the valid question does time
exist and a lot of people say well yeah
time it says time is real but they're
using this notion of ordinary
speech which they automatically bring
into their dissertation you can't do
that you got to define the word exist
before you can use it in science it's at
a very important word so important that
something that we define physics as the
science of existence physics tries to
elucidate what exists out there business
only deals with what exists okay it does
not deal with what does not exist okay
so where do we go from here well he
defines time finding okay here it is the
definition okay so what does area say he
says that time is number of movement
quantity of movement interval of
movement he's referring to some kind of
numbered as he's gonna apply to he's
going to talk about seconds essentially
or minutes or whatever measure they had
in those days number of movement in
respect of the before and after okay
before and after have to do with time
but with qualitative time okay it's
qualitative whereas he's talking about
number which is quantitative see when
you say yesterday today tomorrow you're
talking about qualitative time okay
those are before and after you know that
is qualitative the notions we have of
time but from a qualitative standpoint
and that's the only thing that you can
bring into physics if it serves any
purpose I don't even I don't think it
does in any sense but maybe there is I
can't say that it doesn't we don't use
time and when I say we don't use time
specifically I'm referring to the fact
that we do not use numbers we do not use
seconds minutes years whatever because
we cannot explain anything with those
numbers with those units okay that's the
issue time is a measure of motion and of
being moved okay so he's talking about
measure of motion that's what he's
referring to time is number two now in
the before time is not motion but number
of motion and what is it
rest also can be in in the number of
motion okay I don't know what he meant
by rest because as far as I know no atom
in the universe is at rest at rest with
respect to what you know you can be at
rest you can be standing totally still
and you're moving with respect to
Jupiter because Jupiter is moving so
your distance with respect to Jupiter is
changing simply because the Earth
rotates around the Sun Jupiter rotates
around the Sun and everything in the
universe is rotating around something so
there is no such thing as rest but
that's going to be important because the
relativist
invented the so called frame of
reference they they put a stake on the
ground put a corner in there and they
said well with respect to that corner
you're not moving they had to stop the
universe in order to make their case
mathematically okay I keep that in mind
the rest is very important they don't
call it rest they do we talk about rest
mass for example that sort of thing but
they're gonna talk about frame of
reference and and that's putting a stake
in the ground
time is not motion but number of motion
wind what is it okay as I said it can be
in the number of motion then now is an
end and a beginning of time so time is
always at a beginning at an end so these
are the notions yeah good old area has a
time and this this notion lasted the
hundreds of years you know one guy that
picked up on that and who read Aristotle
quite well and was somewhat of an expert
on Aristotle was this fall here and his
comes about 600 years laters his name is
well he's known as sane always do you
know people and he was more into
religion but you get the the idea with
him where where all this went to and how
how it progressed he says God is the god
of time he didn't say that but that's
essentially what he meant he said look
God is outside of time he created time
okay and he says you made time itself
this is out of his book Confessions
right most famous book of August II and
yes the question isn't what is time who
can easy and briefly explain it who can
who even in thought can comprehend it
even to pronouncing to the pronouncing
of a word concerning it here this guy
reads Aristotle Aristotle Tom's it it's
a number of motion and here six hundred
years later this fall who read Aristotle
quite well he says what is time I still
don't know what time is if no one asks
me I know if I wish to explain to him
yes I know not in others he says like we
have this intuition of what time is
something floating I guess I don't know
the clock going around the hands on the
clock he has no notion he cannot define
the word time and it's interesting that
even to this day you have Stephen
Hawking writes two hundred page book a
brief history of time and the only word
you won't find you find a fine defined
in there is the word time you won't find
in the glossary you won't find in the
body you won't find it you know Hawking
never do what time is but he called it
the fourth dimension he talks about
space time time being part of that
structure but he says he doesn't know
what he's talking about
that's interesting it says neither time
past nor future but the present only
really is there is only a moment of
present time in other words he's saying
there is really no such thing as time
which is I think the only thing that he
said correctly okay he had this notion
that you know time is just the present
this moment now that just past okay that
was that is time not not the past not
the future it's it's always at the
cutting edge between the past and the
future that's the notion that he had and
that's probably the only correct notion
that you can have of time there is no
such thing as time
if before and then he has to justify why
what was God doing before he created
time and his answer is that there was no
time before created time okay if before
heaven and earth there was no time why
is it asked what did you
then what did you dent in other words
you meaning God right for there was no
then when time was not so there was no
time before God created time okay he
moved his magic wants have time let it
be and time became something and started
flowing I guess okay and time began to
exist and that's more or less what
relativists have they call it the Big
Bang they don't call it God God the Big
Bang they say it wasn't set in motion by
God it just is and it started with the
Big Bang that's when time began and so
you ask him again you know what came
before that well before that time did
not exist it was when energy moved right
keep this in mind here's you have
positive energy according to Stephen
Hawking right and he's he was the guru
died two years ago right you have
positive energy negative energy over
here and they're gonna come together and
until that moment even though you got
motion you don't have time okay but it's
when negative energy hits positive
energy that you start having time but he
reverses the movie it's the other way
around he's got this thing called energy
and it divides into positive and
negative energy and that's when time
begins that's I guess the notion of Big
Bang somehow energy splitting and the
whole shebang
blows up you figure it out try to figure
out what energy is in the first place
then you'll you'll make sense out of it
okay so what happened from from from all
these people from the Greeks and
Augustine and all the others that came
in between well what you have is this
group of people okay and what's
happening here is that you have the
Greeks first and they started very
simple they had two dimensions for
example for a triangle and that stayed
pretty much all the way until the middle
of the 19th century when they started
bending the triangles you know they put
it on a saddle they put on a ball and
they
with these warr triangles dandy started
playing around with the dimensions or
with the lines that form the triangle
day they started curving down and
towards the end of the century well then
time began more became more and more
important it started entering the
lexicon of mathematics people started
talking about time okay
and you ended up you know with Einstein
saying that time is the fourth dimension
well not him
someone else was really Minkowski but it
was the fourth I mentioned they started
incorporating time into their evaluation
of location they said it's no longer
length width and height meaning really
coordinates they meant altitude
longitude and latitude to locate a point
and they said well hold it but that's
only the space part how about the time
that was there at the one o'clock in the
afternoon and at nine o'clock at night
nine o'clock at night was somewhere else
so now they had to incorporate time and
somehow they got carried away with that
you know lunacy I caught it and they
ended up with four dimensions of time
somehow they equated time - nothing
mentions really two coordinates but to a
mathematicians like I said the other day
dimension coordinate and vectors are all
the same thing why because they're not
talking about dimensions coordinates or
vectors they're talking about number
lines so when you talk about four
dimensional space hunt now it's four
number lined space time but if they say
four number line space time you first
you wouldn't know what they're talking
about second if you did you would say
well that only says that I need four
numbers to locate a point within
space-time it doesn't mean that
space-time is four-dimensional because
you cannot imagine the fourth 90-degree
coordinate dimension or vector to the
standard three so this is the issue time
does not run perpendicular to anything
and somehow they did they said well it
is but you can't imagine it okay so you
can only approach it from a mathematical
abstract point of view you cannot try to
visualize this from a physical point of
view that's where the problem is again
the question is whether mathematics is
the language of fish
if you cannot even visualize it you
cannot make sense of it if you cannot
put it on the board you cannot
illustrate the four dimension even on
even on film okay because you would have
three dimensions where you going to put
that forth 90-degree angle
specially on a two-dimensional screen so
there's no way to illustrate it and so
what they do they train you to visualize
for it I've mentioned or whatever tester
acts or hyper spheres or whatever okay
by the end of the 19th century they
ended up with this with time becoming
very important 1895 there on the right
you see it that's father time okay and
so is the guy in the left a little more
modern version and he's got this scythe
okay and that's because father time you
know was related to the hardest time
okay and so yeah now they start talking
about time is something a little more
important becomes popularized this
notion of time okay and that's when I
we begin our brief history of
four-dimensional time or time as a
fourth dimension and here's a summary
okay first you have throughout the 19th
century they believed in the ether they
said there's this ether in the
background that forms space itself some
some say that the ether is just a bunch
of particles within space others say
that no space and ether are equivalent
they're the same thing okay so they have
these two different notions and of
course they have they had to explain
what light is and they said what's the
vibration of the ether of these
particles that form the ether that forms
space or whatever and that's the notion
all these people have even to this day
okay except that nobody wants to say the
word ether in mainstream because it's
taboo as one of was it well one of the
Nobel Prizes of physics mathematical
physics said yeah anyways the
michelson-morley experiment in 1887 try
to figure out if there was either
they did they had an interferometer and
here's a version of it so that you can
see it okay and they had this
interferometer in which they sent a
light beam and he wanted to see if there
was a difference in one direction versus
another direction of the when the earth
moved through the ether and they found
out that the case on the right lower
right was not the case the case was what
they verified was the case on the left
in other words that light had no change
in in velocity whether the
interferometer pointed one direction or
another okay and that that's what they
expected with the with the
interferometer they expected the seat
light slowing down or or [ __ ] with
respect to the other beam of light okay
and that didn't happen and so in general
they concluded and I'm not sure they
concluded because they didn't really I
think addressed the issue well enough or
left it dangling there but a lot of
people concluded from that a lot of
mathematicians concluded there is no
such thing as the ether and this was a
big shock because they were talking
about the ether now for since the days
of Newton even Newton talked about the
ether they were all ether as' and now
here comes the the michelson-morley
experiment says look there is no ether
okay then now we got to go back to the
drawing board and find out what do you
mean there is no either so what is light
if light we always held that light is
the movement of the ether the vibration
of the ether and now you're telling me
there's no ether then now we're back to
square one what is light okay
and yeah they talked about ways but then
the waves of what what is waving and so
this this was an important issue and one
of the fellows who addressed it was this
fella here put this back up here his
name is George ditch Gerald he was a
Irishman okay and he says he theorizes
here comes here comes where the
weirdness starts coming into the you
could call it physics it's really not
physics the mathematical physics world
he says theorizes that moving objects
shortened in the direction of their
motion what is known as length
contraction a lot of people say oh I
stand invented Allah now know it came
from fist era when I saw was almost not
even born I said was only 10 years old
in 1889 so III don't think I'm thinking
up with length contraction neither did
he come up with time dilation this came
from these guys okay this this was
before Einstein was even born almost and
so he tortured sterile says well the
reason the michelson-morley did not
detect the ether is because the
interferometer the armed shortened in
the direction of travel it squeezed it
became shorter we have length
contraction of the interferometer and
that explains the difference of ligh
light arrives at the same time you know
from from two mirrors that was his
solution and a lot of people laughed at
him a lot of mathematicians in those
days laughed at him but Hendrik Lorentz
who was a big guy in those days you know
he was uh he was like the Einstein the I
Stephen Hawking of those days and
Hendrik Lorentz said I'm gonna tackle
this problem and he went in there he
developed the mathematics for it and he
says he concludes essentially observers
measured the same speed of light but
arrive at different measurements
regarding when events happened okay and
so he's gonna apply this to both length
contraction and to the speed of light
okay and he's gonna introduce the
observer okay and that's what we start
running into trouble here it is this is
his notion with respect to length
contraction Lawrence Lawrence develops
the Lawrence factor okay which is that
little equation up there and it's not
that difficult to understand okay what
he's saying is see you see velocity
squared V squared
well when velocity squared approaches
the speed of light little C squared
in other words
velocity unite 300,000 km/s right if the
velocity of the object is I don't know
280,000 kilometers per second to 9275
whatever number close to the speed of
light well you have almost one just the
numbers slightly less than one okay and
so if you have one minus a number that
is slightly less than one you end up
with a very small number okay and so
what happens he's got a very small
number he takes the square root of land
that's a smaller number he multiplies it
times the length of the object the real
length or the proper length of the
object and when you multiply that small
number a fraction right times the length
of the object you end up with the length
contraction the contraction that an
observer in motion is going to see okay
that's that's essentially what it is
it's not to do if you go just put some
numbers in there you'll figure it out
it's not not that difficult to figure
out okay and he applies this also to
time okay that's where we start running
into trouble okay because he says look
if you apply my my equation my factor
and you apply it to time you get the
same thing you got a stationary observer
who measures time in one way but then
you have the moving observer okay and
he's got to measure time a different way
and he's also gonna do this little fancy
mathematical calculation he says okay
time dilates time is what shortens time
is what squeezes okay or lengthens
depending on the speed in which you're
traveling so time is not time for
everyone as Newton thought it was at
universal time Aristotle also says that
I I should have brought the reference
but if you read physic you'll find that
time is according to him time is
universal these guys are saying no it
depends on the observer okay that's when
we get to a little bit of trouble
because that we're relying on observers
that's when rational physics we say
there are no observers in science
because they keep introducing the
observer and telling you there
relying on this witness on his testimony
they're telling you what the witness
perceived or measure and you said what
this guy measured something different
than that one over there because this
guy was in motion this one's a standing
still with respect to a reference frame
right and so no we don't deal with all
that nonsense okay and here let me put
it in in a little picture I think I got
it here yeah you suck in here okay here
it is you have Einstein in Lawrence
Lawrence's on uh on the little train
there a little cart that's movie can't
hear it starts okay Lord sees this yeah
I'm sorry I sites he says he see is that
the light coming from Lawrence hits the
two detectives at the same time Lawrence
on Diaz and he sees one hitting one
detector first then the other okay why
because he's moving and so the light
from the event comes to his eyes at
different times because he's in motion
here it is again I said seize him
both hit at the same time the light tone
whereas Lauren sees the light cone hit
one detector before it hits the other
why because he's in motion
that's essentially what they're saying
so what's wrong with this picture
well the what's wrong with the picture
is obvious we don't care about observers
that's killed both observers let's kill
Lawrence and that's kill ice now let's
get rid of both of these guys dead light
hit the two if we have two detectors
there light detectors
well the detectors detected at the same
time or or not that's the only issue and
if they detect it at the same time they
happen simultaneously and they detect it
at different times they didn't happen
simultaneously we don't need an observer
all we need is objectively to put two
sensors there to detect whether light
hit them at the same time or not that's
it we don't need their testimony these
guys are saying look mathematically we
can show that the guy moving visualizes
observes measures detects something
different than the guy who stationary
that was their notion this is what they
had in their minds and that's what we
have today we have a
you know mathematics has developed
around the observer that's why we don't
like to observe we don't like testimony
we don't like witnesses in science the
first thing we do is what we the Mafia
does when you wipe out the witness
forget about the witness and these
people relying on their telling you
mathematically what what witness will
see what another one will see and in the
compare they say we'll see for this guy
time only one second went by before this
guy when two seconds went by that's what
they're telling you we don't care I mean
the two events happened at the same time
or not either the asteroid hit the moon
at the same time that the moon hit the
asteroid okay you can't say well the
moon saw something different than the
asteroid because the moon was more or
less stationary in the asteroid was
moving it's all idiocy
what what mathematical physics has
created with this monster called time
okay so how do we do it in in rational
science well under rational science the
first thing we do is define terms so
that we can use them consistently
rationally scientifically okay here it
is okay we start with the definitions
that mister Aristotle bungled okay you
can forgive him because he was the first
guy to attempt it okay we can say that
poor old area he didn't know any better
but after 2,000 years nobody made any
improvement we don't have definitions
for these words so we have to define
them motion two or more locations of an
object okay we're done if it has two
locations what is the location set of
distances to every object in the
universe so now you can talk about
motion in terms of universal time frame
or or space frame matter frame okay
comparison of two motions okay time is a
comparison of two motions and the
difference especially is you move you
move by definition time requires a
memory a recording device you need
memory you can't do time without memory
and it's interesting that Aristotle
mentioned that as well and again I
should have pulled out that reference
I'll pull it out next time for sure okay
but yeah he mentions that in order to
have time you need to
have some kind of menu got to memorize
something and yes you can't do time
without memory okay okay and here's a
pictorial representation of that motion
two or more locations we have a boxer on
the top and let's assume that the little
balls there thus that's let's assume God
moved his magic wand and made him stand
still completely still motion just means
that the box is changing its distance
with respect to each one of those dots
okay that's all it is time on the other
hand requires two objects if we're going
to introduce a cylinder now and we're
going to compare the motion of the
cylinder versus the motion of the box
okay that's what we're gonna be
comparing and you're gonna need memory
because you're gonna need to memorize
the previous locations in order to have
this sense of time okay otherwise you
don't have time otherwise you just have
motion now you can have time also in the
first film there and the one about
motion only if you compare the box
against its original point it's starting
point then you can if you memorize that
location then yes you can have motion of
a single object but essentially what
you're doing is comparing the motion of
the last frames of the film versus the
first frames of the film okay so so keep
that in mind that's that's the contest
here okay
so here we have who did where am I there
it is here's a you know you say well
what is time
what notions we have to know where did I
get this notion in fact you might ask
okay and here is what we typically
associate with time seconds minutes
hours days years right 60 seconds in one
minute 3,600 seconds in one hour 60
minutes right 86,000 seconds in a day 31
million in a year okay that's the number
of seconds what is a second well a
second is 30 kilometers that's what a
second is it's the distance the earth
travels in one second 30 kilometers
approximately right
we came up with this by dividing the
year we divided the year into
two days then in two hours minutes
seconds that's how we came up with all
this in retrospect okay and so we had a
certain distance we said okay we had one
year here at took 365 days days and
nights right so that was the that's that
was the starting point in fact the the
definition of the word year has not
changed we still say that a year is one
orbit of the earth around the Sun that's
a year it's not measured with atomic
clocks no we don't measure years in
atomic clocks with atomic clocks now we
measured by how many rotations the earth
made around the Sun so if you want to
know how many candles you have on your
birthday cake you don't bring an atomic
clock to your birthday party you know
you count how many years went but how
many times the earth went around the Sun
that's how we measure that okay that's
the definition that's still the formal
definition of year okay and yeah one
second of motion on the hand of the
clock right the second when it moves one
second the earth moved 30 kilometers
except for flat earthers okay the earth
doesn't move there it's the Sun that and
the moon that move around the top you
know the I guess the heavens okay but
for normal people you know rational
people yeah it's the it's the earth goes
365 days to go around the Sun okay globe
yeah and it's our spherical earth joyner
on a spherical Sun okay let's make sure
we get that right and and yeah when it
travels 30 kilometers you got one second
that's what the second the hand the
second hand on the clock okay move one
second okay and here it is just so that
you can see over why it's a time as a
comparison of two motion okay I can get
this thing here yeah there it is let's
see if I can get it here's a pictorial
representation of that okay the earth
moves around the Sun around the earth
okay spherical earth and the clock on
the
right news one second obviously it's
movie both of them are moving right
quite fast but what we're doing when
we're saying one second we're comparing
the hand the second hand on the clock
moving one little notch and the earth
moved 30 kilometers so we're comparing
the two motions were comparing the
motion of the second hand against the
motion of the earth around the Sun
that's what time is comparison of two
motions so if you ever wanted to know
what a second is now you know a second
is thirty kilometers that's what a
second is with that I'll see you what is
it on Sunday and for those of you who
are interested I'm starting the Spanish
starting up I've already had the
channels but I'm starting up the channel
and I think it's gonna be Friday a
couple days I was waiting to translate
the book into Spanish now I did I
uploaded it for those who are interested
you can find it also at rope high
apotheosis calm and I also was
translating a couple articles extinction
articles which is so pertinent today
right we may be headed towards
extinction relatively soon soon in
geological terms right anyways so I was
waiting to translate that as well as the
book now I have done that and so I'm
gonna be uploading those on the articles
on Friday and that's when I start my
channel which is an attack of all first
against the flat earthers yeah that's
true because they made a couple videos
last year on me in August I was going to
answer but I just got sick and then I
decided to write the book and then I
translated and a lot of a lot of stuff
in between including the coronavirus and
all that but now it's translated I
uploaded the book I'm gonna be uploading
the two articles three articles really
to publish them one informal and that's
when I start my crank up my
Spanish channels so for those of you who
are interested remember you
there's always YouTube has this
automatic translation so it's not going
to be perfect I talk in Argentine
Spanish not even the Mexicans understand
us so I'm gonna start that up on I think
Friday if you're interested you can tune
in okay so we'll see you then bye bye